okay yesterday we had this voicemail
from Troy York and I expressed you know
it seems a little sad that Troy York is
living in a totally alternate reality
the eggman is now commenting on the
comments from Troy York and commenting
about whether he feels bad for Troy York
here's the Eggman
take a listen hey I don't feel bad for
Troy York I feel bad for his pets his
kids his wife and meth lollipops
is that for when you really want to rot
your teeth out Wow the eggs I was
waiting for the Eggman typical sign off
with Shalom everybody but he's not no no
Shalom that time okay so listen there
are growing conflicts between frequent
callers on the show you had asked me
yesterday if I was jealous of Troy York
because he just doesn't seem to know any
better
ignorant is bliss ignorance is bliss and
you asked you know what I would I take
that deal right I don't think so I'd
rather be right than be happy
all right well listen you're not
necessarily there there are many people
who don't agree with you fundamentally
and it's America so we had Alice ofle
here on the show we have the freedom in
America to be blissfully ignorant or
informally miserable I don't know I
don't know what to call it I like it on
the bonus show today United Airlines is
again apologizing this time after a
video from 2015 shows an employee
pushing a 71 year old passenger to the
floor
not good I'm going to talk about the
huge double standard when it comes to
Senator Kamala Harris from California
and her performance destroying the
impotent arguments of Attorney General
Jeff Sessions during the day before
yesterday's testimony we will also talk
about New Jersey Governor Chris Christie
whose approval rating has gone down not
to 35% not to 30% not to 25% not to 20%
not to 19 or 18 or 17% or 16% I will
tell you on the bonus show just how low
his approval rating has gone it's not
looking good for Chris Christie david
pakman.com slash membership is how you
get access to the bonus show sign up
today and we'll speak to you then